i'll hop back in the pool
i said
oh i played jumping piglet that previous
game was that nice london game
um i said that
i'll play ponziani
okay so this is gonna be high level
ponziani
i'll see how well prepared my opponent
is
and so far we're actually going into
exactly what i showed in this recent
lesson to fundy
um
the one time
or maybe the it was one of the first
times i played ponziani against a gm in
a tournament
my opponent played this line
play the tournament in the netherlands
against uh
[Music]
back in 2016.
played gm
i don't know how to say his name for
jesus
dutch grand master
i think he played exactly like this
i'll admit i'm i'm already out of
preparation
i think i should just castle and carry
on with life
leave the tension there's a nice pin
happening
a6 is very logical
yeah so now i can take it would give
away the bishop pair but
i don't think there's too many other
great options if i play this i
welcomed
knight before
bishop e2 looks too passive
and the prospect of taking knight c3
yeah let's do that
another question is whether to trade
queens
which i don't think i want to do
[Music]
i guess i have to be ready for bishop d5
it's actually kind of annoying
the d5
and there's a line rookie one takes and
then takes
let's have queen e2
oh queen e2 there's bishop c4
i have queen f5 takes takes
we trade everything
i'll have more space but slightly
damaged structure
that's an interesting decision i think i
should just play knight c3
not spend too much time
oh i can address yeah remind me after
the game i'll try and address a
comment from
whatever your name is
okay now bishop g5 looks nice
i'm just trying to go for quick
development and now if we trade
i'll be pressuring the bishop also
preventing casting because queen h7
mating ideas
of course i'm trying to take and
[Music]
force black to blond cloud
f6 is probably not too attractive
for example takes takes in rookie one
okay so this is a line
um
consider taking the bishop
i don't think it's necessary i probably
just take and then
decide next move whether to take the
bishop
i mean black's probably in the castle
and we'll get some end game
[Music]
i shouldn't be worse here like sometimes
it's risky playing ponziani against a
strong player
where they'll be like very well prepared
but
i mean this is probably close to equal
but still imbalanced
i have a little bit more space with the
pawn
um
also a bit more development
h6 is a bit surprising
because i was probably going to take the
bishop anyway
i think i'll take and play f4
maybe i should have considered this move
but
okay life goes on let's play rookie one
and go for f5
i'm trying not to get too low on time
here
okay f5 f6 looks nice
even just f5
what is black gonna do queen c4
but then i rook lift
and gets wool
[Music]
yeah these pawns are really nice looking
so rookie four
[Music]
ah rookie four queen here
and i might lose a pawn
wow
so i could play king h1
[Music]
but also play queen f2 which is
a very useful looking move
so preventing checks along the diagonal
also just trying to get to the king side
to mate
and now rookie four's a
probably a bigger threat
rookie four almost drops a queen
[Music]
black would have to move here
it's really close to a queen trap
am i trapping the queen
wait a minute rookie 4 queen d3 rook d1
i don't see how rock saves the queen
[Music]
that's so crazy because the position is
so open
[Music]
but oh the queen has c6 never mind let's
play rookie 4 anyway
i forgot the queen had c6
i'm just realizing i forgot to share the
secret idea from that last game
okay i'll have a few things to address
after this game
okay now i think the queen's trapped
unless i have another blind spot
i mean of course black can take
but then i've ricky won in the end and
should be winning
uh
oh i have a blind spot or dubai
wait
oh wow there's a funny line
so rook d1 queen takes e4
and then rook takes d8
rook takes g8
knight takes e4 rook d1 and then i lose
back my queen
that's just a fair trade and i probably
lose a pawn in the end
that's crazy
so maybe i'll play h3
man what a funny line
i wonder if i can play h3 and then count
as black stop work d1
also have e6
play h3
i make some luft
there are some cases where h3 supports
the rook on g4 as well
okay so there's queen g7 here which is
a very passive move for black
might be necessary though i mean there's
also a5
the game plan is to
get ready to play rook d1 just see what
black is up to
[Music]
yeah so now i should be considering
these pawn moves
let me start with queen g3
this feels reminiscent of the
first game i played against jumping
piglet
whereas kind of equalish opening but
like
getting kind of a big attack in the
middle game
so my threat with this move is to play
rook g4
beware piglet has hose
as what
wait
hops oh has hops oh okay
that makes more sense
because it can jump
i was really trying to make sense of
that
i was thinking like a
garden hose
anyway okay
uh this move this move
this move
let's move this move
oh this move this move this move this
move
that's mating
okay let's do that
i also have 94 coming
oh there's g5
and what is g5
maybe i play
queen each four first
also have rook t1 to consider
so many moves
i shouldn't take too much time here time
is getting low
yeah i have to be aware of the piglet
hops
so i play queen h4 first to prepare f6
and then that way
this pawn would be sucked to
um defending h6
potential mating square
king h7
i have this move
at this point i'm just throwing
everything at the king's side
throwing all the mud at the piglets
it's a mud fight
i feel like the piglet enjoys having mud
thrown at it
but i enjoy throwing mud
it's a win-win
so i'm threatening to probably play this
and then this and
there's going to be just everything
targeted
including the king
uh where's my meat
oh is it really made in two
it's made in two
oh this is such a funny maiden two
queen h6 black has three legal moves
if this is mate if this is mate and if
king takes its mate
it's like the finished uh carlson
karjakin
in 2016.
oh no my queen
okay that was fun
that was a nice way to finish off the
attack i didn't see that coming until of
course rick h8 was played
okay hello to
youtube feel like there's nothing to
address did rx and g7 also work
yeah i mean
rook g7 and knight f6 were the first
move that came to mind
um
[Music]
once i saw queen h6 it was it was clear
so i didn't really look further
yeah it was a crazy maiden too
[Music]
because you wouldn't expect this
position to just be made like
immediately
uh rook g7
does not work
it looks like it should be working with
all the attack but
apparently white is somehow better after
it takes an e6
yeah no way i would be
finding e6
with all the different possible moves
thank you the musty kumquat
oh fun fact if uh
if we look in the masters database
it's my name
i was telling the truth
but how do we pronounce this this name
i think i said projects
but i think the j is silent so maybe
it's
bruisers or priesters
um first name roland
actually fellow truss streamer
he goes by monkey chess on twitch
we had a game
it was uh
the leiden open
it was actually my first ever tournament
in
europe and
yeah it was during my ponziani phase
i actually had like a better position at
some point in this game
yeah
so
some crazy moment i could have played
knight a4
and been winning
um
unfortunately i went on to lose that
game
so
[Music]
in the game i just played
we went for a slightly different line
does the engine not like queen c2
uh engine prefers other moves like this
queen c2 is logical
[Music]
you know i guess this is like
this is one of the problems with
ponziani at least this line specifically
where fox like really well prepared
engine does give a slight edge for black
um but as we saw the position was still
like okay to play
yeah after here
is actually doing fine
yeah so i i guess i should show this
line
um because i really wanted to trap the
queen with rook t1
and the queen does look trapped here
but uh after queen makes e4 crazy move
and if i take right away then i'm losing
because i have to block with my queen
if i take the rook first
it almost looks winning but uh
yeah that can take lose the queen and
then win it back
in the very end there's knight c4 i
think i'd just be worse here
or it's just equal
[Music]
because i have knight c5 at some point
anyway i played h3 kept queen's on the
board and
i should show the uh the carlson
aryakin
so slightly a different position but
same move
and same type of like made into queen
sacrifice thing
[Music]
so
[Music]
i guess in my position i had a few more
attacking pieces
carlson was a bit more of a minimalist
so yeah in the carlson game
uh queen h6 and
if
g pawn takes there's rook f7 mate and if
king takes
uh rocket shavers meet
cool idea